[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing a couple of things
both pertaining to the powerful dark
wizard lord voldemort
first we'll be looking at whether or not
the death eaters were actually aware of
the fact that he was a half-blood
and next we'll be discussing how
accepting the death eaters would be
of a half-blood in their ranks when it
comes to dark witches and wizards the
death eaters are as bad as they come
followers of lord voldemort who obeyed
his every bidding
in an effort to cleanse the wizarding
world
they were a group of pureblood radical
supremacists
ever bloodthirsty and always more than
eager to incite fear in the hearts of
their enemies
but what's ironic about the death eaters
is that their founder
and leader was a filthy half-blood
himself
their words not mine in fact the death
eaters were originally formed when tom
riddle
still attended hogwarts between the
years 1938
and 1945 however tom's group in school
were just the precursor to what we now
know
as death eaters back then they were
called the knights of walpurgis
the knights of walpurgis was a group
comprised of exclusively slytherin
students
as many of their core goals and
perspectives as a group
coincided with the beliefs of slytherin
house these
students were certainly a bit morally
dubious and dumbledore once described
riddle's gang
as a mixture of the weak seeking
protection the ambitious seeking glory
and the thug-ish seeking a leader who
could show the more refined cruelty
voldemort was messed up i don't think
that's something you could argue
but what i find so curious is that he
amassed legions of followers
to pursue a cause that by definition
would enslave
himself voldemort would always refer
negatively
to his parentage over the course of the
books films
and we find out fairly quickly that
voldemort's father was indeed
a muggle he liked to pretend that he
wasn't associated with his parents at
all
but there's no escaping your heritage
however the books and films
are a little bit conflicted on whether
or not voldemort's followers
the death eaters were actually aware of
his heritage
after all is the level of disdain that
they felt towards non-pure blood
actually real if they knowingly follow a
halfblood
did they know voldy's dark dirty secret
when tom riddle was first sorted into
slytherin he was still just a young boy
a confused young boy that grew up in an
orphanage
he knew nothing of his heritage but this
void of knowledge quickly became his
obsession
and in chapter 17 of the half blood
prince it's revealed that he quickly
became obsessed with it
because he had grown up in an orphanage
he grew increasingly curious as he aged
it was only natural that he sought
answers
as any orphan would and he began looking
for clues within the school
it seems he searched in vain for some
trace of tom riddle senior
on the shields in the trophy room on the
lists of prefects in the old school
records
even in the books on wizarding history
finally he was forced to accept that his
father
had never set foot in hogwarts it was
actually voldemort's uncle
morphin gaunt that eventually revealed
his true heritage to him
in the same chapter of the half blood
prince there is the following exchange
between the two
i thought you was that muggle whispered
morphine you look mighty like that
muggle
watmuggle said brittle sharply that
muggle what my sister took a fancy
to that muggle what lives in the big
house over the way
said morphin and he spat unexpectedly
upon the floor between them
you look right like him riddle but he's
older now any
he's older than you now i think on it
using this dialogue we can infer that
voldemort became truly aware of his
heritage
sometime around the age of 15. there are
a few parts of the book's films
that sort of suggest that the death
eaters knew of his heritage
though it is never stated directly to
delve into this further
i'm going to start with the segment from
page 231 of the chamber of secrets
where voldemort reveals that some of his
intimate friends at school
knew of both his old and new identity
he pulled harry's wand from his pockets
and began to trace it through the air
writing three shimmering words tom
marvolo riddle
then he waved to the one once and the
letters of his name rearranged
themselves
i am lord voldemort you see he whispered
it was a name i was already using at
hogwarts to my most intimate friends
only of course
you think i was going to use my filthy
muggle father's name forever
what this tells us is that some of tom
riddle's closest friends
were aware of both names which confirms
that there were people he went to school
with
that knew of his heritage however while
it is likely that these same individuals
went on to become death eaters that's
not confirmed
additionally in chapter 23 of the
half-blood prince
it is revealed that fellow slytherins
found it amusing
that voldemort's father was a muggle
despite the fact that he was a
descendant
of salazar they're in himself this
suggests that it was never a secret
among his peers
that he was a half-blood this leads us
to our next and more important question
who did he go to school with and did
they go on to become death eaters
a line from page 463 of the half blood
prince
gives us a clue good gracious is it that
time already
you'd better get going boys or we'll all
be in trouble lestrange
i want your essay by tomorrow or its
detention same goes for you
avery the above passage mentions the
names of both lestrange and
avery both of whom we know go on to
become death eaters
if they went to school at the same time
as voldemort and we know that they
become death eases later on
it is fair to assume that they would
qualify as the intimate friends
that voldemort had previously mentioned
by lestrange
i am of course referring to the ancestor
of rodolphus lestrange
the lestrange that we know to be married
to bellatrix
in chapter 35 of the order of the
phoenix harry mentions voldemort's real
name
tom riddle to bellatrix which seems to
enrage her
you dare speak his name you filthy half
blood
she responds to me this pretty much
confirms that bellatrix
one of the oldest death eaters is fully
aware of riddles real
name and background but i wonder what of
the rest of the death eaters
bellatrix was at the top of voldemort's
ranks and his right-hand woman
so it only makes sense she would know
but some of the death eaters
though they followed him loyally were
nothing but ants to voldemort
insignificant disposable soldiers would
he disclose his deep
dark secret to them did they know as it
turns out
probably in the goblet of fire voldemort
addresses all the death eaters in a long
monologue
in his monologue he discusses his need
to acquire his father's bone
to regenerate and the necessity to
travel to little hamilton
where his grave was located the books
imply repeatedly
that little hangleton is a small muggle
community
which is definitely not a place that a
pureblood family would live
also voldemort's father's gravestone
clearly reads riddle
so if the death eaters didn't already
know that voldemort was a half blood
this would have been a dead giveaway as
they would have been easily able to
recognize that riddle
was not the name of a known pureblood
family
so now that we know that the death
eaters were all more than likely aware
of his pure blood status
this begs the question why did they
accept him despite being a half-blood
why did they follow him when by doing so
it almost contradicts their core values
as death eaters
i think it comes down to a couple of
things first of all
though he was a half-blood voldemort was
still technically the heir of slytherin
the founding father of slytherin house
slytherin was the one who perpetuated
the anti-muggle
purist views in the first place and he
was heavily respected among slytherins
the students most likely to become death
eaters as
voldemort was his descendant it only
makes sense that
this would in a way balance out his
half-blood status
next voldemort condemned his family in
fact voldemort pretty much killed
every tracer family that he had left all
in an effort
to leave his old life behind him it was
clear that voldemort was a devout
follower of his own cause
and this further proved that voldemort's
passion and willingness
to eradicate any trace of his muscle
heritage proved
that he was the real deal and i'm sure
that the death eaters respected that
the last and most important point worth
mentioning is that voldemort was simply
too powerful to question
sure they could have spoken up against
him but if they did
i doubt they would have stuck around for
much longer his power was alluring
and this is one of the reasons that
peter pettigrew changed allegiances
regardless of what you thought of him he
was this imposing figure
that would seemingly eventually dominate
the wizarding world
if you can't beat him join him and
that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember sometimes we
have to choose between what is right
and what is easy
[Music]
you